hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in his short but important essay
how to seem virtuous without actually
being so Alistair McIntyre is going to
to outline for us four important
questions that he takes any serious
person who really has the virtues in
mind to be addressing in one way or
another and the formulation that he
actually has is when someone utters what
he or she takes to be a well-founded and
thought out judgment on the basis of
some tolerably systematic and coherent
understanding of the virtues he or she
is characteristically committed to
giving answers of a certain kind for
four different questions and we're going
to look at those in just a minute but
think about what he's actually saying
here so when somebody is uttering a
judgment when they're saying something
like oh that person is brave or that
person is self-controlled or that person
we could talk about the vices as well
that person is is cowardly or that
person is stingy or that person is
greedy right so
well-founded actually based in something
thought out not just uh complete snap
judgments but actually you know some
basis of thought and then he says some
tolerably and I think that that
tolerably qualifier there is pretty
important systematic and coherent
understanding it doesn't have to be a
completely coherent completely
systematic so this means that people who
are studying the virtues trying to
cultivate the virtues but don't have a
synoptic understanding of it because
they're not Aristotle or Sena or pick
whoever else you want or Alistar
McIntyre for that matter they are making
judgments that could be you know
tolerably systematic and coherent uh
based in in that of the virtues and so
they have to give answers and again of a
certain kind they don't have to be
absolute cover everything sort of
answers but they have to be answers that
are to some degree satisfying and so
what are these for questions now it's
important to note that
McIntyre sometimes promises to do things
in a certain way and then doesn't quite
do that so not all of these are actually
framed
as questions but they can all be turned
into questions you know for example
question number three uh he doesn't
actually have a question in there anyway
but uh that that's okay so what is the
first question well he says it has to do
with
counterfactual judgments and so what are
counterfactual judgments if you're not
used to using that terminology you have
been using them your entire life a
counterfactual judg judgement is saying
what would have been the case or what
would a person have done or what would
my response be if conditions were
different than they actually were so
they're contrary or counter to how
things are the facts and you're saying
what if a different set of facts were
the reality that I was facing and so
McIntyre
says we can say what would this person
have done if things were different he
says we engage in counterfactual
judgments about what he or she would
have done if such and such would did
which did not in fact occur had occurred
or if such and such which is not yet
occurred were to occur what am I
committed to in saying this thing so we
can say oh you know I have no problem
being temperate that is controlling my
uh desires for bodily Pleasures but what
if I went to Las Vegas you know the city
proverbially of sin where there's a
million opportunities to do indulge my
appetites in every way and what if it
was old-fashioned Vegas where the
buffets were super cheap and I could
stuff my face all all day long now I'm
not in fact doing that but how would I
behave would I still remain temperate or
would I show myself to a glutton or
would I be abous and be like oh I don't
like that sort of thing right these are
counterfactual judgments and as McIntyre
is going to point out answering this
question is important not just in terms
of what I didn't do because the
situation didn't call for it but what I
would do in the future what if somebody
does give me an invite to some place and
it's like desert world you can have
every kind of dessert that you like and
they're all super tasty would I indulge
myself right or uh what would I do in
people think about these situations all
the time what would I do if I was placed
in this situation that demanded courage
now I'm too old to fight in a war but
what if the enemy came here to America
would I join the uh resistance movement
and fight against them or would I be a
collaborator well those those are
counterfactual judgments about things
that have not yet come to pass so
Futures right so this is important
because what determines whether you
really are virtuous or not is the range
of things that you know if we tweak the
situation you might do differently so
that's the first question he says the
second uh question concerns the type of
reason for acting as he or she does so
if we judge that somebody who is brave
or generous or just uh he says that it's
the con contention of every tolerably
systematic and coherent understanding of
the virtues that to be virtuous it's not
sufficient just to do what a virtuous
person does you have to do it
motivated by the right reasons Aristotle
frame this in terms of not just the on
the account of but also knowing what it
is that you're doing being conscious
of choosing something so McIntyre says
the relevant actions need to be
performed for what are taken by
adherence of that particular
standpoint uh as the right types of
reason and so he's going to frame this
actually in terms of a question a little
bit later he says for what reasons did
this person act as he or she did and she
he also points out this is very
important important the second question
is not logically independent of the
answer to the first question what
counterfactual judgments are entailed or
implied by this judgment that someone is
virtuous if we want to know why somebody
would have behaved differently in a
hypothetical situation we also need to
take into account um the motivations the
reasons that they would be able to
provide themselves and others and so he
he's got a great example here of
somebody uh encounters a live grenade
now are they going to pick it up and
throw it away to demonstrate their
baseball prowess as an outfielder
outfielders in baseball have to throw
the ball very far right or are they
doing it in order to save a child right
the one is not really a virtuous thing
to do the other is definitely a virtuous
thing to do you know if you're placing
yourself in danger just CU you want to
look cool or try out your skills uh
that's not really courage so that's the
second question now let's look at the
third question and McIntyre doesn't talk
about this one all that much but this is
actually very important and we should
point out so McIntyre a little bit later
in this essay is going to say hey I just
want to let you know that um what I'm
really doing here is from an
Aristotelian point of view pleasures and
pains and whether we feel them or not in
relation to the actions that we do or
witness incredibly important from an
Aristotelian virtue ethics perspective
not as important from some other uh
virtue ethics perspectives like say
stoic philosophy or you know some of the
others that we might uh bring up as
Alternatives so McIntyre says a third
question to which an answer is
characteristically
implied is what was it both in the
situation that and the action which
pleased or pained the agent and he says
to the question about The Virtuous
agents reasons there has added this
question now he reframes it here and
this is very important to pay attention
to his responses of feeling and desire
so we have Pleasure and Pain which are
affective right and we have feeling
feeling is emotion so this could be the
uh emotions of say anger or fear which
are not exactly the same thing as
Pleasure and Pain and desire now some of
the emotions are in fact desires for
example Aristotle will Define anger
which is a very long complicated
definition in the rhetoric as including
a desire an orexis an affect that is
aiming at retribution
or um you know imposing something on
another person right so uh the affective
side of our being
incredibly important so we've got the
cognitive side we've got the affective
side we've got these counterfactual what
would they do in different situations
and then the fourth really ties it
together he says a fourth question to
which some answer is characteristically
presupposed and here we get a very long
question right is
um what range of different types of
action performed by some particular
individual in different types of
situations provides a sufficient warrant
for such an ascription of a virtue to an
individual so there's a few technical
terms in here when we say um sufficient
warrant what we're saying is good enough
reason right good enough justification
what just ification do we have for
ascribing a virtue to this particular
individual um ascription means saying
that that's the case of them right so
maybe that's that's clear enough at this
point now notice what range of different
types of action in different types of
situation what we're talking about there
is what in other contexts we might call
transfer from one context to another so
if somebody is going to be viewed as
courageous or just let's just use those
as examples we don't want to see them
behaving courageously just in one kind
of situation or justly like honoring
obligations in one type of situation
maybe they can be
courageous uh when it comes to the
battlefield but they're actually cowards
when it comes to facing up their fear
years of doing public speaking or um
facing the trauma that that they need to
look at in therapy or dealing with other
people in their neighborhood or perhaps
they're just in the workplace but then
with their neighbors they behave in a
very different way if that's the case
then we wouldn't say that they're
actually virtuous we want to see sort of
an even Keel across a variety of
different situations or we could say
areas of life and if that's the case
then we can say that the person is
actually virtuous and so he he goes on
and he says um that you know there's
this additional requirement that
instances be of sufficiently different
types to justify the relevant set of
extrapolations to counterfactual
conclusions and the relevant set of
inferences to judgments about the
agent's reasoning and about what it is
is in which he or she takes pleasure or
by which he or she is pain and he says
to this fourth question adherence of a
variety of systematic standpoints Give a
more precise detailed and determinant
answer than that presupposed by those
who are doing no more in what they say
about the virtues than giving expression
to present day commonplace usage if you
really want to be claiming that somebody
is temperate or somebody is generous or
somebody uh even you know to take one of
Aristotle's uh other virtues has a good
sense of humor has the virtue of wit
well then this fourth question which
ties the rest of them together is
incredibly important so notice we can
frame these as questions we can also
frame these as sort of subject areas in
which we see what virtue actually
consistent any virtue ethics theory that
is worth calling that according to Al
aliser McIntyre has to
address these four questions and do so
in a relatively systematic and coherent
way that he takes it is the essence of
any genuine ethics of
virtue